$10.6 BILLION.
SO HOW CAN WE INSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HOW TAXPAYER
FUNDS AND WEAPONS ARE USED?
CONGRESSMAN GREG STUEBE SITS ON
THE HOUSE FOREIGN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE.
HE JOINS US NOW.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR BEING
HERE.
YOU SUPPORTED THE WAR IN
UKRAINE.
YOU VOTED FOR FUNDING FOR
UKRAINE, FOR HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
NOW THIS AMOUNT SAYS 10 POINT
WHATEVER BILLION DOLLARS.
YOU SAID YOU HAVEN'T RECEIVED
ONE REPORT OF ACCOUNTABILITY?
>> I VOTED FOR THE FIRST TRANCHE
WHICH IS THAT $10.2 BILLION.
THE SECOND TRANCHE WAS
$40 BILLION.
WE HAVE SPENT A TOTAL OF
$54 BILLION IN UKRAINE.
I VOTED AGAINST THE LAST FUNDING
AMOUNT, THERE WAS NO GUARDRAILS
HOW THE MONEY WOULD BE SPENT.
CONGRESS STILL HASN'T GOTTEN ANY
INFORMATION.
I SIT ON FOREIGN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE.
FOREIGN AFFAIRS HAVE NOT GOTTEN
INFORMATION THE ACTUAL WEAPONS
WE TRANSFERRED TO GET IN
UKRAINIAN HANDS.
HAVE THEY BEEN UTILIZED?
WHAT IS THE STATUS.
HAVE MONEY GONE TO OLIGARCHS IN
UKRAINE?
WE DON'T KNOW.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS.
THERE IS NO GUARDRAILS OF THE
LAST FUNDING TRANCHE,
$40 BILLION, MORE THAN CUSTOMS
BORDER PATROL, BORDER PROTECTION
COAST GUARD COMBINED WE NEED TO
BE FOCUSED ON AMERICA FIRST AND
NOT ALL THE OTHER ISSUES
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
RACHEL: IS THIS THE PENTAGON WHO
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR GIVING YOU
THIS REPORT?
>> IT'S THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND
PENTAGON.
THEY GO BACK AND FORTH THE WAY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
DONE IT WITH AFGHANISTAN BOTCHED
WITHDRAWAL THE STATE DEPARTMENT
WAS IN CHARGE OF THAT PROCESS.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS IN IN
CHARGE OF MOST OF THE FUNDING IN
UKRAINE.
MOST MILITARY TRANSFERS.
MOSTLY DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSES
AND PARTLY, DEPARTMENT OF STATE.
RACHEL: IF REPUBLICANS TAKE
CONTROL OF CONGRESS CAN YOU SAY
WITH HOLD POWER OF PURSE WE'LL
HOLD FUNDING IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AND PENTAGON IF YOU
DON'T GIVE US THE REPORT?
IS THAT A WAY TO DEAL WITH IT?
HOW DO YOU GET THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AND PENTAGON TO DO
THEIR JOBE?
>> NOT ONLY POWER OF THE PURSE
WE HAVE TAKING MAJORITY, BUT
OVERSIGHT.
DEMOCRATS WILL NOT OVERSEE
JOE BIDEN'S HORRIBLE
ADMINISTRATION.
WE'LL BE A CHECK AND BALANCE TO
THE DECISIONS HIS ADMINISTRATION
IS MAKING.
BRING IN THEIR OFFICIALS, DIE
POSING THEM, HAVING SUBPOENA
AUTHORITY.
THAT IS WHERE THE REAL POWER
COMES WHEN WE TAKE THE MAJORITY
BACK TO GET ANSWERS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WHO IS COMPLETELY
IGNORING REPUBLICAN CALLS FOR
TRANSPARENCY.
RACHEL: AMERICANS DON'T WANT A
PROXY WAR WITH RUSSIA AS THEY'RE
SUFFERING SO MANY FAMILIES.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS.
THIS IS A SLAP IN THE FACE.
I WILL MOVE TO ANOTHER TOPIC
WHICH IS THE BORDER.
WHICH AS YOU KNOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF PROBLEMS AND YOU POINT
OUT RIGHTLY THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
FUNDING FOR BORDER PATROL.
SO MUCH IS GOING FOR LACES WE
DON'T KNOW.
LAST WEEK A GOOD SAMARITAN
DISCOVERED 70 POUNDS OF COCAINE
WASHED UP ONSHORE IN THE FLORIDA
KEYS.
BORDER PATROL WITH SHERIFF'S
OFFICE RECOVERED DRUGS WHICH HAS
ESTIMATED STREET VALUE OF OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS.
WE HAVE A MASSIVE FENTANYL
PROBLEM.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION THOUGH
THIS DISCOVERY AND THE ALL THE
PROBLEMS IN THE OPEN BORDER?
>> WE HAD ENOUGH FENTANYL COME
INTO THE UNITED STATES TO KILL
SIX TIMES THE POPULATION OF THE
UNITED STATES ALL UNDER
JOE BIDEN.
THE DRUGS COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER IS ABSOLUTELY
ASTRONOMICAL BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
OPEN BORDER.
OVER 3.1 MILLION ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS SINCE JOE BIDEN HAS
BEEN PRESIDENT.
THERE IS ONLY 2.1 MILLION PEOPLE
THAT LIVE IN MIAMI-DADE COUNTY.
THAT IS MORE THAN THE ALL OF THE
POPULATION OF MIAMI-DADE COUNTY
AND ANOTHER MILLION ON TOP OF
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY ATROCIOUS.
WE HAVE AN INVASION AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER YET THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO GIVE
MONEY TO UKRAINE FOR A PROXY
WAR.
WHEN REPUBLICAN GET CONTROL,
THAT IS WHERE THE POWER OF THE
PURSE WE USE THE APPROPRIATIONS
PROCESS, YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T
SPEND ANY MONEY AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
TO ALLOW ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO
COME INTO THE COUNTRY.
RACHEL: I HOPE OUR LEADERSHIP
WITH THE REPUBLICAN PARTY DO
THAT WITH THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
THERE WAS A LOT OF NEWS INTO THE
RAMP UP OF THIS WAR AND NOW
WE'RE HEARING NOTHING ABOUT THE
MONEY.
AS YOU SAID IT COULD HAVE GONE
INTO THE HANDS OF SOME PRETTY
CORRUPT OLIGARCHS.